how was I supposed to know
that something wasn't right here
[Music]
[Laughter]
outside
[Applause]
no I I have a Saint Bernard
that's really similar yeah if you do
your scared Pig I'll do what you do yeah
okay okay
[Applause]
all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I think it's all cool right now right
oh that's your water I'm sorry now a lot
of people don't know this but uh Eddie
is in fact a highly trained Master
magician are you a member of the magic
circle
um no
[Applause]
because we have here just a totally
ordinary coloring book oh this is
totally ordinary oh but Eddie can do
magic with it isn't that right Eddie I
mean
are you sitting comfortably children
no oh well
ordinary thing but you mustn't touch it
so excited so
so I loved Paul Daniels you probably
won't know the late Paul Daniels was an
amazing magician that used to be on
telly every Saturday night I was
obsessed with him and I this is my
moment to be on television doing magic
Ben are you ready I'm ready I'm ready
this is a coloring book there is nothing
weird on the or bizarre about it other
than it says the word magic on the front
of it
uh so there is actually nothing in the
coloring book I'm showing you do you see
there is yeah there's nothing in it but
Ryan yes
will you blow on the coloring book
no harder than that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay
let's let's see what that's done shall
we
oh
wow
[Applause]
okay so the next stage is so we've got
now we have pictures Ben we have
pictures
um will you blow on it
give me your full smog
okay
was it hard enough
we talked about this man no it wasn't
hot but I'm a wizard
[Applause]
I've been sitting there awkward
don't spoil it
and maybe for full-on Marvel like
will you give us a spell Ben
as a Gazette
drumroll
[Applause]
[Laughter]
in terms of the uh the trapeze skills I
mean do you still have them so if for
instance there was extra please could
you just slip your shoes off and get on
a thing and just go nuts um you know
my trapeze outfit today uh the heels are
a little difficult oh okay
is that a no I mean oh are you is it a
yes maybe
Maybe
[Applause]
not I hate to let people down but I do
not have my stunt team here and I do not
want to hurt myself
well thank you very much
yeah the only thing I can do is wiggle
my ears oh see already we're thrilled oh
oh you're really doing it
oh that is impressive well done
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah and did you know that Cara
Delevingne can beatbox you're beginning
to get annoying now the modeling the
actors
look but you can beatbox can you
seriously people yeah
there's two different kinds I feel like
I'm going to show you both okay two so
this is the inner mouth one which I'm
going to show you
skills
okay that's what that is yeah
what's the other one
um
[Applause]
thank God
I'll keep it yeah do it sell it on eBay
in the first Ted movie Seth you you gave
some challenges to Mark who was the
famous uh 57 girls names this time you
gave him another list of 57 things
that's right but you cut it out
now how did you know that he told us
I still wake up in the morning saying
this [__]
it'll be on the blue surnames
yeah what was happening is we were doing
a scene where Ted because it was such a
great moment in the movie that maybe
we'll throw back to it and then uh or
maybe he'll just maybe study this thing
for four months and then not use it but
um yeah so it's all these movie names
can you still do it yeah I could still
do that's all I know I mean I think
about this [__] oh my God can you really
57 movie names okay Zola Veda Kenobi
Palpatine covers in Balboa Rambo Grizzle
stiffer pickle gum colion Wonka Savage
stance like the Higgins do little
Poppins bomb Blowfish like your social
hair du Franco so McFly bag and
splitskin Ventura Montoya burgundy
scissors
[__] con
it's time for party pieces everyone so
uh so apologies Catherine we'll start
with you Catherine what have you brought
us I found this very intimidating and um
I think
I think I can make a noise like a baby
crying
it's a party
like a newborn crying okay okay
I did only try this out today
oh that is so good
oh okay okay Keira Knightley
oh God I wish I yeah all right watch
this actually this is cool this is good
wait for this I can play my teeth
I can play raindrops keep falling on my
head I mean I can play anything you want
but like let's go with raindrops though
you've chosen that time otherwise I'm
wearing a jacket where I can't quite
bend my arms so I don't quite think do I
need to put your hair back
so I'm not using your microphone
I think this mic will pick it up okay
fine okay wait a minute oh I haven't
done this in a while
foreign
[Applause]
yes so if you come over to the unicycle
okay can you really do this yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I can like sort of do it are you
gonna start to cry and tell us a
friend's been running
but um sort of like I I
kind of in the play right I just need to
come on riding it I don't need to get on
it on stage would you help me get it yes
yes all right
oh the sword of the Lord is filled with
blood here we go
[Applause]
okay right give me some room man
come on
we've got another win we've got another
one we've got another one you can you
can both do it together here we go oh
look at you
hey smart I'm gonna just get up don't
crash into each other you sure Meryl
there is another one
again
somebody go
amazing
foreign
[Music]